hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
is this Lisa
it's Lisa Malik she's back she's back in
action guys today is December 6th we
still don't have access to the channel
so no idea when this video is going up
but we're filming it anyway because
that's what we it's the only choice we
have right now thanks for being here
welcome hopefully this video gets 5
views or something yeah yeah so today
we're gonna check out a video 10 movie
moments where actors weren't acting this
is from an awesome channel called Screen
Rant we should be experts that we should
be experts that's how we met acting
class mm-hmm-hmm is the improv acting
classes there's a real acting classes
you can take Disney Disney tiring yet
it's like Disney coaching Wow
whatever let's let's check this out
magic on movie sets to make audiences
believe what is seen on screen is
actually real like mess wit real acting
yeah we find out at the end of this
video it's me and John everyday who's
who called following throughout the
years the scariness of it also still
stands but the real horror was actually
on set especially for Shelley Duvall but
her performance in Kubrick's film was
genuinely horrifying
as she was tormented by Jack Nicholson's
character and his descent into madness
while people were looking down but the
reason why Shelley's performance was so
believable and compelling was it because
it was actually real well heavy duval
endured some torture Kubrick wanted her
for the part but he was also her biggest
critic in order to make sure she seemed
weakened and frantic he kept her
isolated and brutally abused her on Oh
my members to make ignore her he even
made her perform the baseball bat scene
127 oh my god the scene even made the
Guinness Book of Records for the most
hates ever done for a scene with spoken
dialogue her red puffy eyes were a
result of genuinely crying she stated
that she would cry for up to 12 hours a
day oh my
because she gave an incredible
performance and we can't imagine anybody
else in the role but do you think he
pushed her just yes you think so yeah
she gave a good performance a very
colorful language and of course yet
another Oscar nomination from Leonardo
DiCaprio which he sadly didn't win this
yeah he improvised that yeah he did
that's really funny he does it before
scenes to relax himself in get his voice
to draw he was doing it before building
that scene and they were ready to move
on to the judge but before they could
Leonardo DiCaprio asked him what that
was all about
then promptly suggested to do it in the
scene once McConaughey did it he also
improvised convincing Leo to do it as
well
[Laughter]
oh he really flew a bike in front of the
moon that was a mistake
real friends a young boy named Elliott
it's a wonderful story full of adventure
friendship love and of course science
fiction yeah what is so marvelous about
this movie is that we believe et is real
the story is just amazing but what
really drives the believability home is
the performances the actors give so how
do you get genuine reactions
well Spielberg had everyone on set act
as an actor if the special effects
designers test out movements before
production even began so the illusion
wasn't broken it makes sense right in
order to get the most genuine reactions
from drew Barrymore he didn't show her
the puppet before the scene where she
first sees him so her screaming when she
sees et and his stretchy neck are
totally real living breathing alien dies
sobbing reaction shot really really
believed that she had passed away dumb
kid she didn't really believe that the
Birdman tighty-whities
part of what made Alejandro Bernie
choose oscar-winning film Birdman so
awesome was that it seems to be one long
continuous shot naturally making
something look like it's one continuous
shot Wonder has it's commonly known
requires a lot of choreography planning
and of course emerging challenges but
the Birdman team was ready to roll one
of their most challenging scenes was the
scene which riggan who is played by
Michael Keaton he's locked at a Broadway
st. James theatre wearing only his
underwear he has to walk past fans in
Times Square who are staring at him to
get to the theaters main entrance it
sounds simple enough
except reproduction couldn't shut down
Times Square and
a group of screech drummers who dance
and perform nearby this kept tourists
and passerby more entertained than a guy
in his underwear but those crowd
reactions are legitimate and you know I
was actually out in Times Square in his
undies what a cool actor to do that yeah
your punch in Fight Club the first rule
of Fight Club is don't talk about Fight
Club do not talk about psycho
what's the name we're gonna go ahead and
break that rule sorry Kelly there's a
scene in which brackets and we're Norton
to hit him as hard as we can the
direction was to throw a somewhat neat
punch and it ran shoulder sounds simple
enough but just before the cameras
rolled director David Fincher told
Norton to hit Brad in the ear anyway how
would you react it's the most iconic
scene in the Judd Apatow film is hands
down the chest waxing sea scene makes
the top of the list as one of the
funniest scenes and the experience of
going in for your first time in the pain
that Corral exhibits is totally
relatable in fact it almost seems too
real doesn't it
well it actually was oh really did have
his chest wax during the movie that's
his real hair yeah nice very furry torso
wax as he didn't think you would burn
that much obviously he was incredibly
mistaken as his screams curses and
hilarious phrases in the movie show the
pain was certainly real and gave us some
hilarious moments during the scene my
gosh although we still aren't quite sure
why he screams at Kelly Clarkson Carell
said that he went home that night his
wife was horrified when she saw the
Hannah face staring right back at her or
should we say the Anna Wintour
Terminator 2 what happened here fights
back it's time for futuristic robots and
scary technological takeover yep we're
talking about the Terminator series
which gave us the awesome badass
character of Sarah Connor Linda
Hamilton's role of Sarah Connor wasn't
him especially in Terminator 2 where she
set the standard for my all-time
favorite movies a real life so it was a
natural fit but it turns out Linda
wasn't acting the entire time in one
scene a staff is silenced she was in was
worth the beating of her but the actor
kept raining it back because he didn't
really want to hurt Hamilton but noble
effort except for the fact that every
time he failed they had to reshoot the
scene over and over to make it worse she
had to fall down to her knees on hard
calm oh yeah this damn horse spitting it
back out of Hamilton so in a later scene
where Sarah attacks the same staff
character she openly beat the crud out
of him with a wooden oh
camera cuts are the whole series being
absolutely kicks the helmet yeah I heard
about this that is exactly what happened
to Viggo Mortensen during the scene in
the two towers when Legolas Aragorn and
Gimli find a pile of work bodies I think
merry and pippin were killed and Aragorn
ends up kicking a helmet down the hill
ego did this take four times and on the
fifth take he screamed and fell to his
knees it was later found out that he had
actually broken two of his toes twenty
enough this one the best
tape and the one that appears in the
film domitius knish I'm sorry but all
questions must be submitted in writing
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
they didn't let them see the room until
it was time to fill in their eyes what's
actually real remember that terrifying
boat ride seen the one where things get
old psychedelic and it seems like Willy
Wonka's losing his marbles that scene
was a surprise for the rest of the cast
who actually thought that Gene Wilder
had lost his mind keeping things from
your actors is definitely the best way
to get a genuine reaction it might end
up leaving some of them towards a scarf
Gene Wilder I said didn't prepare Peter
Ostrom who played Charlie Bucket or his
rage when he reprimands him for stealing
the fizzy lifting for
the scared book on Austin's face it's
totally real they'll be quite all right
[Music]
don't tell me that's real I came at the
year I was born
sassy and clever boy who survived
Christmas alone while some bandits tried
to break into his home this would
normally be had cause for concern but
Kevin was one creative kid created a
series of booby traps to fool the bad
guys well it turns out that it wasn't
all a total fun facts Culkin was
actually left permanently scarred by a
bit of over-enthusiastic method acting
on Joe Pesci
what she avoided cole kid on sets and
then he would genuinely be afraid of it
in a scene with the robbers hang him up
on a hook and she says I'm gonna bite
each one of your oh my gosh one at a
time actually what did you think which
of these was your favorite are there any
moments that we may have missed be sure
to let us know in the comments below and
before you go here's the answer to the
emoji quiz did you get it right be sure
to let us know and as always thanks for
watching
Wow great video screen rant you guys can
subscribe to Screen Rant
they're a great channel Lisa you've been
on some movie sets yeah with your acting
career thank you for that the quotes
well because you really have acted oh so
then why are the quotes are usually I'm
like underlining it oh you're an actress
nothing has been like this though like
at this extreme over half of these
people are scarred for life and I said
that during this video and for the
performance for the performance but what
about those little children I mean the
only one Willy Wonka I mean that they
had the psychedelic yeah I'd but that's
not terrible at least they're not
scarred like seeing a magical Chocolate
Factory that's fine yeah but like the
little boy in home alone holy cow can do
that well I don't remember him getting
his finger bit in the actual movie I
remember he's about to bite the finger
but they might have cut it out of the
actual film that is pretty far on Joe
Pesci's end by two little kids finger
and take some of those mother think of
that you know what I mean yeah I'm like
some mothers that are like oh yeah do it
do it for the film we need to make money
you know they have some crazy ones but
then like if it were my mom she would be
like dying you know like her little
daughter's fingers are being bitten it's
different if it's a little boy no it's
not it's not no it's the same that's its
problem yeah it's about this it's
equivalent thank you for that don't buy
a little what I learned today I'm the
real rejects channel like what the
shining Stanley Kubrick is known to make
movies that are really hard to be on set
for and that he's known to do a lot of
takes a hundred twenty something takes
yeah she cuz this whole movie she's
suffering she's suffering she was
legitimately tortured yeah this entire
filming process and what's kind of funny
to me about this situation is that when
people look back on the performances of
The Shining everyone thinks of Jack
Nicholson and no one really brings her
like if you're a fan of The Shining
you'll bring her up hello I'm Shelley
Duvall but no one really brings her up
when she gives just as powerful of her
performance and even more authentic one
I think well because Jack Nicholson
hands it up where
as she really is authentic and truly
terrified she's a powerful actress but
that is a question what's the fine line
between getting a good performance and
how you're actually treating a human
being on set I think he made the right
call
I think if it brings a better
performance it's about making money
she was like in prison I would love to
know cuz like I said I have not watched
this film so I don't really recognize
her as an actress but I'd love to know
if she went on to go and do more things
hello or maybe if that's how all
directors treated her because she's a
she's not a good person
do they just love her so much and hated
her acting that they had to do this to
her I mean they said that she was
Stanley Kubrick's biggest critic so
maybe it was some form of punishment to
considering the characters also getting
punished but the wolf of Wall Street
this isn't a mistake it's a proviso
which are always the best true and
Matthew McConaughey came up with that
himself was a good acting warm-up
technique before I even saw this film
that was famous people like at my school
when I was going to school they were
doing that all the time and like I
wouldn't know what that is and where
it's from you haven't even seen the film
yet Matthew McConaughey is probably one
of his most famous moments right there
yeah good for him just banging on his
chest that's his claim too far does he
do it to get his voice lower I forget
why honestly boys lower a few years
et about that I mean I was a little kid
once and if you're an actress on a set
did she really believe that this was an
alien like I could believe The Scream
reaction being real of course in the
script it probably says she has to
scream but I feel like okay if she
hasn't seen the alien yet and the effect
comes up I could believe that being an
authentic scream she really felt that
but they must have been really worried
that she wasn't gonna be often yes you
can't do a take where you see it and
then take it away and do it again
without seeing it so they didn't even
give her a chance and maybe try maybe
she did just imagine et was dying and
she gave a great performance of tears in
that moment and they've stripped her
away from the power of her own
imagination by saying that her little
kid self actually believed this is a die
I don't believe that creature like dying
like that that is pretty sad so like
when you're on set with a bunch of
lights and crew and take to get this
shot it's a totally different experience
this looks like such a fun thing to do
with Michael Kyle this is x squared my
first thought is like to think get
everyone to sign up yeah because you're
no one's face is blurred out no I know
that's a huge crowd you would have to
get like a bunch of waivers for this one
shot and I imagine they have to do a
couple retakes at least to make it
happen so how authentic was it you know
what I don't know and the thing is if
there's one place you could walk around
in your underwear in America it's gonna
be five square that's the one place you
can probably get oculus I want to
recreate this exact scene just on an
iPhone for having you follow me around
thank you to hear that people lisa says
she can imagine me in my no take now for
sex
okay this is a little too far from me
well it's crazy Brad Pitt's done like
four films I think three or four films
with the director of Fight Club and this
was their second or first one together I
forget the last you know together after
that I think is an emotional sport
acting is an emotional game I could be
more on board for what Kubrick did to
that actress whose name I'm horrible at
remember and I'm Shelley Duvall in the
shining then basically hurting your
actor yeah and he's a big guy he's a big
guy he's a big she's Brad Pitt punched
him in the ears that's pretty extreme
pretty rate for a very memorable moment
in things I've seen the movie that's a
memorable moment yeah especially to hit
someone to ear such an odd place to hit
someone which is really painful hit in
the ear so but to me that's a little far
to me that's that's that's far it's cool
he was on board
like we say scarred for life but this
could literally the waxing cp-40 oh yeah
I've known for the long since Luther
came that was that was part of the
promotional market of is like when I
redid talk show everybody was saying
like that's a real really proud of it I
wonder if I would do that I've done I've
got on like parts of my leg wax before
just to see how it felt it's it's pretty
painful
yeah but man Majan your chest hair like
when he's really bleeding that's real
blood I feel like you would do it if he
didn't talk about it too much first like
to people like if you didn't get too
many opinions you're just like yep I'm
doing it today let's go do it like just
be impulsive and do it why why would I
be impulsive about I only do it if I
wanted attention
why else would I get it oh but of course
you would get attention that would
happen regardless cuz you just got your
chest waxed
yeah yeah this is your man wax his chest
did say you're gonna make it
uncomfortable I did I mean the best
moment so it's like when Viggo Mortensen
kicks that helmet and he breaks his toes
and it leads for a very real reaction of
loss that was an accident
yeah and that's his fault yeah that's
his own fault of harming himself good
job it's one thing if it's a if it's a
thing with like a director putting an
actor
I'm way emotional or physical if the
actor has a mistake that he brings unto
himself and it makes her a good moment
then kudos that's like a magical night
yeah good for him and he didn't break
you know he has broken toes right here
yeah I heard Hotel passion of the
christ' Jim Caviezel actually got
crucified to play Jesus oh yeah yeah
that's a pretty big film what second day
you possibly believe in me yeah well
guys are there any movie mistakes you
can think of that made it into the final
cut I'm not talking about continuity
errors talking about actual moments that
were real mistakes I feel like I make
constant mistakes in my life that are
never magical oh yeah that's life man
that's life life subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell you
can follow us on patreon it's like a
second youtube channel or patreon so
become a patron oject today Lisa
mihalick has her own YouTube channel she
is uploading on it she doesn't just have
an account she actually has physical
videos on her channel editing 1 right
now actually I've seen at least half of
one and it was good thanks so much
order of the other ones it was good well
I try to view other people's YouTube
videos like how people view our YouTube
videos you only watch a certain person
whole thing because I'm supportive
I'm Shelley Duvall